iron fist is the latest show to be added
to the Netflix MCU after daredevil
Jessica Jones and Luke Cage and now I've
seen the entire season I'm going to be
reviewing the whole season not just
episodes 1 through 6 or the first
episode that some critics have done
strangely I've actually watched all 13
hours of this show and I'm prepared to
review it I like iron fist he was never
one of my favorite characters I never
really viewed him as an essential read
but due to the three previous Netflix
shows that I highly enjoyed I was
excited to see iron fist and I was
hoping that it would be pretty good the
basic plot of this is that Danny Rand
returns from a 15 year absence he was in
a plane crash everyone thinks he's dead
but secretly he's been training at
Kunlun this monastery in which he has
learned to harness his energy to become
the iron fist he can make his fists glow
and he can do amazing things with it and
he's also like a kung-fu master he's
also having a difficult time proving
that he is who he is because no one
wants to believe him and he sounds like
a crazy person he's been in a monastery
for 15 years in the middle of nowhere
and he's saying all these random things
and no one really gets him anymore
so he has to prove who he is while also
fighting against the evil hand and
becoming friends with colleen wing who
runs her own dojo she takes in kids off
the streets
tries to give them a safe haven tries to
teach them how to fight and their two
ideals go hand in hand now I'm going to
get into some minor plot points of the
first two episodes not spoilers just I
can't really talk about the show's plot
without talking about some of these
storylines when Danny returns from his
isolation he wants to go back to his
former business this is now being run by
his two friends joy and ward and quite a
bit of this show's run time is taken up
by a lot of the things that go on this
corporation rather than iron fist being
iron fist and doing a lot of really cool
iron fist stuff it tends to focus more
on this company when Danny makes a full
of himself somebody is filming him and
then there's bad publicity for this
company they're trying to work through
various legal problems and litigation
they're being sued by people who are
getting sick and a lot of the show is
bogged down by this company and the
choice to constantly focus on this as a
main storyline see where other shows
have filler that tends to happen
the later seasons when the show is
starting to run out of creativity one of
my favorite shows of all time is
Dragonball Z but I have no problem
admitting that pretty much the entire
Majin Buu saga feels like filler there's
so much filler in that saga that I was
like okay they probably should just
ended this after sell you could even say
that that show could have ended after
the freeze of saga but they wanted to
make more in the case of the first
season of iron fist there's a humongous
amount of time dedicated to whole plot
lines that feel like filler but this is
the first season and they're treating a
lot of these storylines with quite a bit
of time for instance Ward and his father
who everyone thinks is dead is actually
not dead and he keeps going back to him
and this guy eventually becomes a very
serious antagonist and there's a lot of
time dedicated to Ward and his daddy
issues and where some of it can be very
interesting for the most part it's just
kind of boring and you want to get back
to what's going on with iron fist and
Colleen because that's the most
interesting storyline in the entire
first season there's a lot of stuff with
the hand which we've heard about
previously and other shows which is also
a lot of fun and very very compelling
but the show keeps reverting back to the
RAND Corporation and a lot of really
boring subplots that it simply ways down
the pacing of the show let's talk about
Finn Jones as iron fist he's received a
lot of criticism due to his performance
even before people even saw the show
they wanted somebody perhaps it was an
Asian American to play this character
and they've called it whitewashing while
whitewashing is when you take a white
actor and give him or her a role that
was meant or written for someone of
another race Danny Rand in the comics is
a white guy born in New York so this
isn't whitewashing it's just they were
trying to be true to the comics but
certain fans of the comics are also like
well maybe you could have been more
progressive and look in all honesty
after seeing the full first season it
wouldn't matter if this guy was red blue
or purple the writing for his character
is very weak a lot of people have
labeled Finn Jones as the problem and
his performance does have issues he
spends a lot of the time monologuing
about how I am the iron
look I spent 15 years of training not
you me
I am the iron fist not you guess what me
I'm the iron fist look my hand up it's
not working right now because they don't
want me to do the iron fist thing too
much it's cheesy I guess but I am the
iron fist it's not all Finn Jones his
performance does have some really good
moments and you can tell that he is
really passionate about this it's just
that the writing for his character isn't
compelling in the least
he's a very bland hero and in this case
this is probably the first time in the
MC use history where the casting of the
main hero hasn't been just 100% perfect
because up until now they've basically
made the perfect choice for casting a
character for the most part not every
character I'm talking about the main
hero in the case is maybe like Tilda
Swinton and dr. strange that could have
been somebody else but she was fine in
that movie I'm not saying she did bad
it's just that casting there was a
little in it not so much but in regards
to the main hero of every franchise
they've always really done a great job
here I'm a little off and on with him
and that's really how I feel about this
entire first season I'm a little off and
on with it
it takes about till episode 6 to really
get going episode 6 is actually pretty
great also I think the best episode in
the entire show is 12 the one right
before the season finale that episode
was awesome really really fantastic
whenever the show tries to have some
energy it picks up quite a bit I don't
want to sound like I didn't like the
first season of iron fist
it's just disappointingly a bit hollow
they do try to tell a compelling story
in regards to Danny's past but the hero
in this show that I like the most and my
favorite character in the entire first
season is easily Colleen winged Jessica
hen wig is fantastic
her action scenes are a lot of fun she
gives quite a bit of energy and passion
to them and her more emotional sequences
are also very fulfilling she also has a
very rich and conflicted past she's
easily the best character in season one
without a doubt but whenever the show
really does feel like it's finally
getting going it reverts back
that subplot with Harold Meacham one of
the main antagonists of the show and
it's just bland I just don't like that
subplot I don't really need it in the
show and so much attention is given to
that family and it's necessary to tell
this story but man it's just kind of a
drag to get through those scenes let's
talk about the action scenes because
they've also received a lot of criticism
the editing could be better the action
and choreography could also be better it
suffers from the first few seasons of
Buffy the Vampire Slayer syndrome I'm
wearing a shirt because I'm a big fan I
finish the show by the way really liked
it but the first two seasons of Buffy
you can tell instantly whenever Sarah
Michelle Gellar is replaced with a stunt
woman towards the final few seasons they
got better and she did more of the
action stuff too but this first season
of iron fist you can always tell
whenever a stunt double replaces Finn
Jones he does do more than I would
expect and it's easier in like daredevil
because you can put a mask on the guy
and you can hide it better but the
action scenes here are fine they're okay
and that's just not good enough after
the amazing action in daredevil and even
Luke Cage has fantastic action sequences
this takes more of the route that
Jessica Jones took where you have
someone who does have superhuman
abilities but they choose to not use
them or really focus on them and so you
get more stuff about his company and
just more simple kung fu sequences in
every once in a while he'll glow up that
fist now in Jessica Jones the storyline
was actually extremely compelling and
the antagonist versus protagonist was
really fun David Tennant and Krysten
Ritter they were both really great
together and the main storyline of that
show I was invested there were episodes
that drag just like in Luke Cage and
daredevil every single one of these MCU
Netflix shows has a few episodes really
all right let's get going here I had
issues with daredevil season 2 it wasn't
perfect a lot of the Elektra storylines
felt a little and you know wasn't the
greatest but here it's just the main
story isn't really that interesting and
so the fact that he doesn't do a lot of
his Iron Fist stuff makes it kind of
boring I gotta say I mean for a show
called iron fist
I wanted more iron fisting
I'm going to stick with that I would say
this is the weakest of the most recent
MCU shows on Netflix it's not awful
I think the Rotten Tomatoes score is
actually extremely low far too low and I
would say that a lot of that does have
to do with the fact that a lot of
critics in their reviews admitted that
they either are just reviewing the pilot
or the first six episodes that's not
cool I mean you wouldn't just watch half
of a movie and review it you know you
wouldn't just be like oh I just watched
the first hour of say the Avengers okay
I'm done I'm going to review it now that
Iron Fist would say that's dishonorable
I am the Iron Fist not you I am gonna
fixed that score is far too low I mean
that's like spant four stick level come
on the show is not that bad
it's got problems the lead is not the
greatest he could be considerably better
but he could also be written better too
and that's a major issue my favorite
character as I said Colleen wing she's
amazing I'd like to see more of her in
season two and I hope that for the
defenders Iron Fist is a more light
hearted and fun presence and not so
tortured and cry-baby ish because
unfortunately he is that way in the show
there are good episodes there are good
moments there are some compelling
storylines but in the end iron fist
season one was a mixed bag for me and
I'm going to give it a C+ could have
been better had some issues but it is
not as bad as some critics are saying
that's for sure give this show a chance
watch it for yourself try to get through
episode six and I think it picks up
after that but you're still going to
have some problems with the show more
than likely unless you just love things
because thank you so much as always for
watching I also want to thank Adam
tickets ATO em because they are
sponsoring my videos if you guys do
download the Adam tickets app on your
Android or iOS and use the coupon code
Chris 5 you can get $5 off your first
order now this is a fantastic app for
movie fans I've used it myself
you can browse all the new releases look
for the release dates and the schedules
and the theaters and the show times you
can also pre buy concessions which is
awesome they have a fantastic option for
paying separately where you all can go
to one film
set it up and then paste separately so
you don't have to worry about io u--'s
which is very annoying with other
services you don't have to do that here
it's a fantastic service so please do
use that coupon code Chris 5 and you can
get five dollars off your first order
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I hope you check out iron fist
and decide for yourself because there's
a lot of bad buzz out there this show
has some good things you know has some
things to offer it's not a terrible show
I think it's worth a watch if you're a
humongous fan of the other shows but for
some people it is going to be very
middling and middle-of-the-road which is
kind of how I feel about it guys thank
you once again for watching look forward
to my reviews of ghost in the shell' as
well as gifted you guys are the best and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you